to get her eyes tested we've always had
to go to an optometrist and that can be
a pain but now maybe we don't have to go
is it the quick and cheap alternative
that you've been looking for welcome to
your online eye exam a company called
upturn ative is an optometry alternative
claims it has a new online eye exam
that's as good as an in-person exam will
measure how clearly you see heel to toe
steps away from your computer gently
cover your left eye and press the button
to begin it's hard to believe that this
could replicate what optometrists do but
the author of the book bottleneck errs
who research this exam says it is just
as good as an in-person exam at least as
good and sometimes better some
researchers indicate how could it be
better it's over the internet this is
the beauty of technology select the
square with the sharper lines you look
at the computer while following
instructions on your cell phone
optometrist Steven Lee found adapter
'native in this TED talk he explains
that he did it because a patient
complained about how difficult it was to
get to his office
she'd skip work and waste most of her
day to spend just a few minutes with me
that's when she stopped me she said dr.
Lee why can't we just do this at home so
he invented a way to do that select
which character looks different all you
need is a computer and a smartphone
that's it this is really foolhardy and
really dangerous the American Optometric
Association says a home test is
unacceptably risky because no
optometrist is there to look for
diseases so I said to that company
spokesman sick people are not gonna be
diagnosed sick people are not allowed to
take the exam well how do you stop on
you've asked them questions absolutely
just like you would be done in your
optometrist office optometrist is not
going to be able to screen you for
diabetes they can't take a blood test
the Apter 'native computer program does
ask you medical questions if the program
suspects you have a disease the company
won't give you a prescription for firs e
to an eye doctor it is a tool that
allows you to have it take a test or be
screened those results are then reviewed
by a licensed ophthalmologist not
good enough says the optometric
association they want to force everyone
to go to an eye doctor
they're the bottleneck here and they've
persuaded 13 states to draft bills
banning at home tests groups of doctors
that basically said patients like
yourself should not have the right to
make any choices in your vision care
bottleneck errs like the optometrists
have clout in legislatures because they
give the politicians money when South
Carolina's legislature banned the
at-home test then Governor nikki Haley
spoke up for the patients she vetoed the
ban she said it was anti-competitive and
it is but the legislature was so
beholden to the optometrists that they
overrode her veto
it's as if car makers got together and
got laws passed forcing all of us to buy
the most expensive cars but often
consumers don't want all Cadillacs
sometimes they are satisfied with a
Chevrolet many Americans never visit any
eye doctor this test at least gives all
of us a choice what is right for bidding
a person from seeing unless they first
allow you to invasively test their eyes
I didn't have to go through an invasive
test your prescription is in sight in a
few days they got this prescription
which turned out to be the same
prescription I get for my expensive eye
doctor and I paid just 50 dollars on
average optometrists in my town charged
$95 it's good to have a choice these
glasses were the correct prescription
for less money the optometry Lobby
doesn't want us to have that choice no
they don't
bottle necker's make life worse for you
you